ciao busi diciamo ai solisti tonalità
1969 challenge slime in cui abbiamo le
mafie più bellissime a tutto onorate e
glitter se vi ricordate abbiamo già
fatto la challenger tre colori di acqua
colorata
questa volta abbiamo altri colori e in
più metteremo anche di twitter
allora la cosa fantastica challenge e
che poi uscirà un mega di glee slime se
vi ricordate nell'altra salento mio
posto ci è venuto un bellissimo gb che
c'è tanta ma se non l'avete vista dopo
questo video andate a vederlo mi la sua
casa di da cui cliccare e della nasa
anche nei commenti come tutta questa
coraggiosa perché altrimenti non c'è un
rotolino volante un bel laici attacchini
del video potrete votare se vinco io
servizio e vitale nel mettere il
sondaggio fa in base al slime 10 e
faremo una traccia la ingestibile
consigliati sicuri nei commenti che
altre sale allora primo round
vediamo se l'istituto che con anime che
ti capiti no ma mica sono cristo bisogno
di restare perché gli imbrogli tutti ad
icloud
e poi questo che è un po color turchese
bellissimo così chiudiamo in più però
sento pronto
ecco io morgia ma non mi piacciono
io vorrei siccome poi andremo a
mischiare il colore o paura testa marone
non vorrei colori chiari team mi pare
chiaro successo che non ha pari
questa volta ne frega io allora mi merda
si pedala sì allora che colore ha detto
che volevi natali non più non me lo dici
più aspetto che mischia
finalmente allora dai cieli tutti i film
sei rosso il blu il rosso fi western
indico con la paletta per non far cadere
bravate
quale di queste male perché non ne so
che dicano nessuna ok perfetto allora
siriano in camera ok ma perché non la
sto toccando perché più avanti fermati
da ma toglie la benda il giocatore
simbolo mito di colore chiaro è bello
partire con una base rossa perché poi
come sia sempre colore diventa la base
già a mettere la mia acqua colorata per
me li facciamo vedere da vicino rampi
bn2 via addio questa slide uscirà super
g e un acquitrino sta diventato rosa
perché il rosso mischiato con il bianco
si schiarisce diventa rota è viva
[Musica]
abbiamo giocato benino blu beh insomma
volete spiare commentato il tempo t
mischiando tutto dove il mio verte il
mio verde
[Musica]
no ma adesso io lo do lo racconto va
bene perché colpito è limitato a porta
da tutti qua ok che si crea in che senso
come la cosa si è scoperto che cosa la
prossima l'alimento 24 che imprese prima
volta sono funzionando a qui dentro non
scompaiono mai stati tutto dopo lo
stagno e tool è se l'effetto poi
dobbiamo andare un piano nel mio
rosa scaduto proprio non mischiamo che
corriamo diventato un po violetto non
chiara il tuo emerse dalla spagna
non basta diventato berto sbaglia
celeste e poi sono migliori della sosta
io sono contento per ora perché è
diventato un rosa chiaro chiaro non
rinunceresti lo è che un bellissimo ecco
cosa ho detto ci vediamo utilizzare
cartomagia capolino sotto ma e ho capito
tutto è filato tecnica per vincere
sempre con me dice fatto no mai
allora sono qui c'è 12 34
ok voglio non voglio neanche dire il
nome in quel colore non te lo dico
[Musica]
questo
tanto di mercato
vero è che ogni volta che devo dire non
lo facciamo apposta non so come cavolo
sia possibile però ogni volta together
magri tutto è sicuro sei tu che lo metti
in posti strategici noi perché lo prendo
il mio libro io lo metto in posti
strategici perché so che tu solo in
allenamento tu andrai cadavere quindi a
faccia che una volta però secondo me non
dispiace a pensare in modo diverso
insomma io so già come pensi tu e tu non
perche in passato nel cibo e su tutte le
rotte e verde marrone il numero 80
vediamo grigio sta venendo grigio era
bellissimo e un bellissimo un polo rosa
adesso è diventato materno coraggiosi e
il rosso grigio metallizzato e un po
ingrigito purtroppo più forte
chiamava il mio grafica totale dove
vorresti lo so già che non vorresti il
giallo dicendo che c'hanno con celeste
fa come fa il resto fa bene siamo fatti
allora aspetto sono tutte e tre qua devo
pensare ad un investitore
quindi lei messo secondo me non l'hai
messo qui ma l'hai messo qui quindi io
prendo questo giallo inventari preparati
fatte e mai preso in pieno bruttissimo
altro questo qua allora in pratica ascom
è all ufficio colorante verde dopo
giorno il colorante giallo ha fatto una
porzione di gol che può di colorante e
quello come si chiama quello rimuova i
non fumatori
dentro si acrilico quindi anche doversi
altro fortunato perché colore tra più
forte ma sarebbe comunque
[Applauso]
saracino è stato sin dentro comunque
colore giallo quindi rimuginando un po
il senso comunque vediamo verde brand e
verde e veneto no fisco diventato tutto
per torino dove è uscito color verde da
bagno però socialmente un modo per la
notte perché capita il viola diventa
marrone e ti capita la ragione non lo so
come il calabrone uguale invece il mio
come capita il violento meco loro
costante suo compagno l'obiettivo del
silicio sono fortunata l'arancione con
definitivi di meglio che riesca perché
disastro entrambi gli occhi
tu devi sperare che ti esca l'arancione
no che scambiò la perché se ammesse il
viola il mio sarà sicuramente più bello
ma vediamo poi team leader ci capita di
successo anche perché papà da mischiare
dove sarà si scusa
matri è ora che prendo questo
lo so perché magari rumori che il fatto
poi è stato forse non le sa mischiati e
sembrava che non ce lo ha mai cantato
allora tu hai l'arancione vediamo come
diventa una vera che bella questa cosa
ecco la viola e vediamo come diventa il
mio di super digitally con viola lilla
vediamo proprio il colore che voleva
frontali che bello e ora vediamo anche
che di litter si capiteranno wise super
liquido quindi sarà super g glee dopo
con un proprio contento del colore che
mi avessi è cosa loro bebè che ho fatto
i pezzettini di colla gialla dai vecchi
l'arancione proprio quella di vedere
come diversa magari esce rosa bubble gum
dei militi e guarda che bello uscita
zuppa di patate legumi non ricapiti
colore una persona di cenci
[Musica]
sembrano tra un giallo maran si gioca
una aspetta questo proprio il marrone
fuoco si è man one vuole restare questo
prova il fuoco e fuga giovane perché
evoca adulte sono più marroni questa
ragione
e invece no a chi glitter si capì
tassiamo ray twitter una carta vari
aiutato a questo punto vero dai bei per
andare a casa a caso a caso
ok ma è normale e glitter viola questo
qui è andata male che fa latte sembra
quella tragica fine
[Applauso]
cross di questi qua sto pensando in base
al tuo colore
questo aspetto ci sono quasi ok in atto
dai dove stanno
altro non da qui sino a qui e ho fatto
una forma un po ad es
quindi perché sente va riaperta proprio
posto che sti rosa rossi qui siamo al
verde così sono tutti male costante
studio broughton e di cazzo li vediamo
un po come ci sono questi glitter beni
che non sono verdi si stanno benissimo
ma con verde acqua bellissimi ma
bellissimo amore e bay non vedo l'ora di
vedere questo motivo ma che abusivo ma
bellissima ex è proprio bello del tuo
brescia
passiamo al mio che è bellissima guarda
questo guardate questo colore stupendo
vedi come arricchiscono questo slide che
è già bellissimo
finalmente un po di dolore l'hanno
salvato effettivamente previsto ma mi
chiamo una volta a chi voteranno il
diverso tutto sberluccicante tutto
glitterato ok kemal penultimo giorno
vediamo chi li carta forse sasso carta
forse solo dai ma è una gallina perché
l'idea carina na vot inedite farmacista
pero qualsiasi colore si sta beccare
questo come posso dare worry be secondo
di stare attento come di posizione così
gli allora sono da qui a qui questo
vediamo un po come si sta nell'inter non
benissimo guardo si confondono benissimo
sembra un po natalizio natale chi non
ricorda il vitale e lo slime di natale
oa un conflitto come si stanno nel mio
si staranno benissimo perché basta dato
colore quanti massi mai diventato tutto
è meglio di quel marrone lì questo è
color cappuccino si sia colto più chino
il capo chino mischiato fioresi e
perfetto questo e lo slime cappuccino
nome lo slang capodicasa carta con
risata casa bellissima e molto ai
gamberi e particolarmente allegro vitale
pure non ha mangiato cioccolato non sto
[Applauso]
qua
non si vedrà per niente il giallo non
100 kg
adesso il visto della giornata per
questo capita capita senza senza andare
a mettere verdi lista verdi ma iniziamo
da qui prende questo papa sta bene
allora vediamo un po almeno questo
colore c'è troppo che bene non ne sono
proprio sicuro guarda e bellissimo che
il giallo invece qui l'onorabilità di
mezz'ora d'oro e diventa come un pulcino
d'oro
ok ora andiamo ad attivarli ok ragazzi
parli ci metteremo sicuramente commodore
ammesso perché c'è un sacco da quelli
utilizzati vuole stacco di tempo per
attivate e poi vediamo come sono
diventato
sono ancora visibili slime sembra che
sia ancora liquido ma guardate un po è
super g clip e non ho mai fatto un check
list line così cicli e fantastico
super mo di loto e rilassante anche
molto estendibile ma alla fine il colore
è uscito una sorta di violetto chiaro
con slitte l'omesso quanto essa ciotola
perché è talmente cicli che si espande
velocissimo aumento e ora ve lo posso
vedere fuori sarà sotto la tour e vi
faccio vedere quanto si espande alle
super il 80 e allora via un po tanta
tanta e gigante oddio osservato
incastrata tra barche che grande e
bellissimo sono un po il rilassante
[Musica]
mi piace un sacco come
tutti zitti non opere quindi tenteremo
slide si chiama cappuccino speciali il
bollettino allora sembra proprio una
zuppa forma mi sento di broccoli hummer
giorno mi faccio vedere più in bollo
smetto direttamente sul tavolo perché
però guardatene si è staccato subito
molto bene sta per la rosa che allora il
colore diciamo che non è non è proprio
fantastico non lo sapete
lo sapete che quando faccio gli sla il
mio punto più solo simpatia ha chiesto
la bellezza dello slide non è uscito
proprio malvagio a parte il colore è
molto molto morbidoso si stacca non si
attacca dalle maniche di quello già una
è già una cosa molto buono direi e poi
ci sono i vari glitter
adesso tutti a terra quello di anita
diciamo che lo animava anche un bel po
troppo per ora è rimasta abbastanza g
molto di più sulla simpatia che sullo
specchio del mondo mai più e niente
questo è il mio quindi votare non per la
apple ha votate terminale perché
simpatica
perché che vi fa uno slide così bello
slide vomitino più con l'altro per la
consistenza praticamente la stessa auto
è leggermente più
il bello però il colore terribile del
tutto coloro che comunque sono super di
tanti tutti e due
se penso che questo caso lasciando
riposare magari ne diventa diventa
trasparente ma poi mi sono ricordato di
una bomba era bianca quindi non
diventerà trasparente fin troppo figo
caso ziegler allora votate qua chi visse
di incasso e vince vitale ai nuovi di
nomi sono state in bella è che se volete
vedere altri gigi l'islam o altre spalle
i particolari e ora vi lasciamo 14 tutti
cari come dei nostri altri video
cliccate se volete più grinta